I'm very interested in languages but I
was bad at it I couldn't remember
vocabulary very well so I was I would
make connections between different
languages and when I went to university
I discovered to my amazement that there
was actually a whole field full of
people who did this and I was hooked
I'm Brian Jake I'm a professor in the
Department of linguistics to work in
phonetics printer phonetics
is the study of sounds and movements
that we use to produce language
I'm originally from from Pennsylvania
and near there that that's Seneca
Territory Seneca Iroquois Territory I
grew up you know where the history books
talked about the you know these
languages and these people as something
that happened in the past and I was
amazed to discover that these languages
are still spoken by actual people with
actual cultures and it was it was a real
life-changing experience for me if I
were not a professor
being an entrepreneur because it's
basically the same thing they're coming
up with new ideas you're bringing them
to
and you know it's just that in in the
one case your your payoff is knowledge
and understanding and in the other your
payoff is cash I prefer to go for the
knowledge and understanding myself
[Music]